as yellowstone charges forward in its
tenth third season the writers for the
paramount network hit are continuing to
explore new avenues for drama and
intrigue and and around the Yellowstone
Dutton ranch the character Teeter
for instance injects a new dynamic into
life on the ranch being the only woman
working as a ranch hand
after Avery's departure in season two in
a season three sneak peak video from
paramount released ahead of the new
season the actress who plays Teeter
Jennifer Landon joked about landing the
role saying there was a line in the show
that if they were going to get a girl
she had to be ugly or mean and then they
saw me somehow and they said perfect
Teter clearly doesn't lack for roughness
fitting right in with the other ranch
hands immediately and brandishing a near
incomprehensible drawl would you learn
to cowboy
Landon said teeters signature style of
speaking is scripted that way it's
phonetically written she just speaks the
way her family's painted if you're
thinking that Landon looks familiar and
are wondering where you've seen her
before
perhaps in a role with a bit more
enunciation there are plenty of places
to look Landon has starred on several
soap operas over the last decade and
beyond that she's the daughter of
another famous face and Way Out West
television history Jennifer's father is
the late Michael Landon the star of two
of televisions most famous portrayals of
the Old West Bonanza and Little House on
the Prairie
Michael Landon sadly passed away in 1991
the same year that an 8 year old
Jennifer Landon appeared in her first
credited acting gig a small part in the
television movie us written directed and
starring her father after us Jennifer
took more than a decade off from acting
before popping back up in the 2004 film
la deejay a year after that movie
debuted Landon began her longest running
television stent to date starring as
Gwen in the CBS soap opera as the world
turns from 2005 to 2008 the actress
carried the character from a lower-class
teenager to a successful young adult
Landon won three Daytime Emmy Awards for
outstanding younger actress in a Drama
Series for her work Landon had a brief
intermission between soap opera roles
with a one-off spot on the 20
11 episode of house then began playing
Heather Stephens on The Young and the
Restless
Landon's time on The Young and the
Restless was relatively short-lived as
she was let go after 28 episodes the
actress didn't stay out of the soap
opera game for very long though after
appearing in four episodes of Cinemax is
action TV show banshee
Landon began a brief run is Hilary
Nelson on Days of Our Lives yet another
famous soap fans may also recognize
Landon from her guest appearance on
Fox's sci-fi comedy drama the Orville or
from the network's medical drama the
resident just to name a few of her many
TV credits arguably Landon's highest
profile movie role to date was as Ann
McDaniel in the frontrunner the jason
reitman directed political drama
starring Hugh Jackman about Senator Gary
Hart falling from grace as the skeletons
in his closet emerged during the 1988
u.s. presidential election the last
series Landon spent more than a single
episode on prior to Yellowstone was
animal kingdom the TNT drama based on
the Australian film of the same name
landon played amy a megachurch worker
who engages in a brief relationship with
the son of the matriarch of a crime
family played by Ellen Barkin circling
back to Yellowstone
Landon's co-stars say she's a standout
in the new season speaking with
Entertainment Tonight Denham Richards
who plays Colby described Teeter as
quote this entirely new character that I
don't believe anybody's ever seen before
series mainstay Kelly Reilly the actress
behind Beth Dutton also heaped praise
upon Landon saying that she scored the
role of the season what's your name
[Music]
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite TV shows are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]